have you ever stolen anything no no
never never
even as a kid hello this is a trash
taste like criminal record
i mean either yeah guys what's the most
illegal thing you've done yeah
me neither yeah okay so you know how um
in the uk you can get um
what was it um like there's like
bakeries in the store and you have to
tell
on the thing what you got yeah and i
think one time
i i got uh like four croissants
and and i i you know i i clicked what i
thought was for i went through and then
i came
i went to the tail and i paid yeah
turned out boys
i chose the wrong questions right on the
machine big sad
and it was actually cheaper than what it
was oh damn i i i
i i i absolute criminals i know i know
so i left the store
i got about like i don't know like 10
seconds at the store and i looked the
receipt and i was like this is not
this is not the uh because i think i
actually got like the chocolate ones
yeah yeah it's not the chocolate buns
this is
and i went back and i was like hi um do
i need to change like pay the difference
and the guy was like i don't care
it's like 20 i don't think they care i
was like are you sure like i don't mind
paying like i feel bad that i walked out
yeah with 20 pence the wrong but you're
not going to call the cops right like
yeah
but he's like dude i've had that before
like
i did like the you know when you're like
really really young and you do like the
the accidental stealing like the the
completely unaware ceiling
so i did that once like i think i was
like [ __ ] i don't know five or six
years old and like in
australia uh there's like newspaper
stores where like people go
to like newspapers magazines and usually
at the front like cashier there's like
all these like you know
really small cheap like candies and like
chocolates and stuff like that that kids
can buy in one yeah
yeah and i think i i specifically
remember there was one time i went
because i think my dad had to go like
buy a newspaper or something back when
he was still buying newspapers and uh i
picked out like a candy i think it was
like
10 cents or 20 cents or something like
that yeah and i was like dad can i have
this and he was like
bugger off son you're not having that
and we got we got sweets at home
and i remember i don't know why but like
that day i guess i was in like a pissed
off mood or something
i remember being really angry that he
didn't buy me this like 10
20 like [ __ ] pissy little like candy
right
and i remember just being like man like
just clenching my fist being like god
damn it what
god damn and father why did you steal
right now no no i was like i'm about to
steal
no i was like i was just like god damn
it's just clenching my fist really hard
and then yeah we walk out and we walk
into the car and i'm still pissed off
clenching my fist and then
i kind of look down at one of my fists
and i open my hand i've done that before
the candy's in my hand and i was just
like
slowly putting it in my pocket
how did that get here yeah yeah because
i was like something feels weird in my
clenched fist and i was like
at that moment it was like [ __ ]
detroit become human choices like pop
puppy like
do i put this in my pocket or do i come
out clean i was like
put it in my pocket i'm gonna save this
for